[Music]
this is the most productive airplane
factory in the world Boeing's Renton
plant outside Seattle builds the 737 in
all its configurations for customers
globally to build 42 planes a month you
need a pretty sophisticated pretty huge
production line it takes nine days for a
plane to do this loop and be assembled
let's break that down
Boeing's built more than nine thousand
737 since launching the single aisle jet
in the mid 1960s and each one started
life something like this a hollow
fuselage built in Wichita Kansas and
hold by train to Renton once that shell
enters the factory days one through
three are really all about the internals
it's like building a house first
engineers install the plumbing and
electrics and the insulation on the
fourth day the tube becomes a plane the
wings go on along with the vertical fin
or tail workers align them with laser
guidance this is when they fit the
landing gear to day five is for the
horizontal stabilizer install and the
start of functional tests engineers are
putting wiring in now for flight control
and finishing the internal floor boards
they start building the interiors up the
galleys and the bathrooms then on day
six the plane comes alive that flashing
red light means there's power to the
airplane large-scale tests are now
possible like does the landing gear
retract properly it had better the next
time it's folded away will be when this
plane takes off for the first time day 7
and the planes weight is set on its own
wheels and the engines are fixed to the
wings along with their own network of
wires cables and tubes
all through the build systems are
checked and rechecked and day 8 is a
critical test of the flight control
surfaces the flaps and the flight deck
itself the cockpit all these parts have
been checked in isolation
now it's crucial they work together the
plane is nearing the end of the moving
production line on day nine the customer
gets to do a walk-through inspection
before it's towed out of the factory
born in a way into the big wide world
the next off is rent and field for
ground tests of the engines and other
systems and then first flight
[Music]